uh yikes that was a a bit of a a bomb
the drop on this note but um
[Music]
let's see oh
I kept my dad's alcoholism a secret for
years and he used to tell me how he
never wanted a child like me and how I
would never find love
um Flash Forward a few years and my
first boyfriend said I would never find
love either so now I don't feel worthy
of love and won't date because I feel
too broken
hi I hope that that person finds love
and realizes that they're worthy of it
even if it's through like friendships I
mean that's what's been most important
to me is finding I like friends who who
appreciate all the sides of me so damn
my turn my turn I was gonna write
something something funny I'm like